Welcome to the program.
Just wore a t-shirt today
and then seconds before going on thought,
that's not enough.
Went to my car,
found this jacket I've
had forever in the trunk.
That's why I'm dressed
like a man having a
horrible midlife crisis,
old jacket found in the car.
Anyway, that's what you get
when you're making a show
in an abandoned theater during a pandemic.
All right.
Great show tonight, Mike Birbiglia,
very funny gentlemen
will be on the program.
Speaking of funny gentlemen,
(laughing)
I never do transitions, Andy Richter.
Hi!
So you hear that, that was nice.
I did, it was,
I, I thought you were gonna talk about me.
When you heard funny gentlemen?
Yeah, yeah, because I mean, I'm,
I mean, I'm, I'm here basically.
And also you're the only one here.
[Andy] I exist.
Yeah.
I like too that your midlife crisis jacket
is an old jacket.
[Conan] I know.
Meaning, you've already gone through it.
Yeah, I'm,
that's just a, sort of a
hint at how old I really am.
(laughing)
Is that--
You've come to terms.
Yeah, I found my midlife crisis jacket
in the car from like eight years ago.
Yeah, yeah.
It's been driving around.
Do you ever do that?
Do you ever keep a jacket
in your car in case
you're stuck somewhere
and it got cold suddenly,
[Andy] Yes.
you don't have a jacket.
I used to do that all the time,
but now I have a big dog
so there's no room for
anything but dog in my car.
[Conan] Yeah.
Yeah.
You could wear the dog.
I keep talking to her about it,
[Conan] Yeah.
but she's just not amenable.